ans public avec cette question la cour
suprême va t'elle supprimer le droit
constitutionnel à l'avortement depuis
qu'un avis non définitif a fuité dans
les médias pro et anti ivg se mobilisent
aux états unis samia de chiens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des chantent des slogans et des foule
immense rassemblée pour le droit à
l'avortement
depuis lundi la mobilisation ne faiblit
pas ce jour l'est le site politico
révèle que la cour suprême s'apprête à
revenir sur l'arrêt roe versus wade la
décision fondatrice du droit à
l'avortement aux états unis
je suis ici pour vous dire que nous ne
reviendrons pas en arrière nous ne
reviendrons pas à une époque où nous
utilisions des cintres en fil de fer ni
maintenant ni jamais
c'est effrayant c'est dévastateur mais
je suis définitivement motivé pour
continuer à me battre et nous allons
faire en sorte que l'accès à
l'avortement soit maintenue tout est
parti d'une loi de l'état du mississippi
interdisant l'avortement au delà de
quinze semaines la cour suprême est
chargée d'examiner ce texte en
contradiction avec le fameux arrêt roe
versus wade de 1973 qui reconnaît le
caractère constitutionnel du droit à
l'avortement
si elle décide d'abroger cette
jurisprudence alors les etats-unis
reviendront à la situation d'avant 1973
où chaque état est libre d'autoriser ou
non l'avortement sur son sol
de nombreux états ont promulgué ce que
nous appelons des lois d'activation des
que reversus wade sera annulée ces
nouvelles lois criminalisant
l'avortement entreront en vigueur cela
se produira dans environ la moitié des
etats-unis sur les 50 états américains
plus de vingt-cinq reviendrait à une
législation hostiles à l'avortement
la menace d'un retour en arrière de
presque 50 ans sera au coeur de la
campagne des élections de mi mandat
prévues en novembre prochain
pour mobiliser le camp démocrate joe
biden a lui même accusé les
conservateurs de vouloir aller plus loin
si gagner la majorité au congrès
que se passera-t-il si un état change la
loi en disant que les enfants lgbt q ne
peuvent pas être en classe avec d'autres
enfants qu'est ce qui va être attaqué
ensuite sur les neuf membres de la cour
suprême américaine si ce sont des
conservateurs dont trois ont été nommés
par donald trump
ils ont jusqu'au 30 juin pour rendre
leur décision
est ce la fin du droit à l'avortement
aux états unis quelle influence les
idées de donald réponse à la cour
suprême plus généralement encore dans la
société américaine et puis on peut même
aller plus loin sur le poids politique
de la religion chrétienne dans certains
états voilà les thèmes que l'on va
aborder dans ce débat avec marie cécile
nat bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice de recherche à l'iris
spécialiste des états unis au christ de
la démocratie féministe réinventer le
pouvoir c'est aux éditions calmann-lévy
jacques a également françois durpaire on
soit soit historien à l'université de
cergy paris spécial des états-unis
hauteur de l'elysée alors c'est pas sur
notre thème mais c'est votre dernier
ouvrage c'est une bande dessinée publiée
chez mourad maurice édition j'accueille
également jean-claude beaujour bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes avocat international
et vice président du cercle de réflexion
france amérique matthieu croissandeau
toujours à mes côtés marie-cécile nabeul
la cour suprême on l'a vu dans le sujet
on n'a pas encore pris sa décision est
ce qu'elle peut changer d'avis
là cet instant brouillon qui est sortie
qui a fuité donc évidemment il faut être
prudent mais quand même il y avait déjà
un certain nombre d' indices qui
montrait que c'était plutôt la tonalité
qui allait être celle de la décision
rendue dans le cas du mississippi nantes
en a parlé dans votre notre reportage on
ça paraît quand même assez peu probable
que que le document qui finalement soit
rendue officielle diffèrent énormément
de ce qui a été de ce qui a fuité plus
ou moins malencontreusement alors
justement françois durr perez qui déjà
surprenante est-ce que c'est déjà arrivé
une fuite de ce type venant de la cour
suprême il ya eu des mini fit mais pas
des fuites à ce niveau-là 98 pages de
brouillons c'est le fun kraft s'est
quand même très inédit est donc la
première question qui se pose c'est à
qui profite le crime à qui profite la
fuite pour moi le le fameux scaglia
antonin le grand juge de la cour suprême
disait à tous les personnels de la cour
suprême si jamais vous dise ici si vous
allez dans les médias pour diffuser quoi
que ce soit je vais vous faire une vie
tellement impossible vous allez vous en
rappelez donc c'est quand même une
tradition de secret certains disent et
c'est plus secret que le pentagone ou
que le fbi ya rien qui sort de la cour
suprême alors pourquoi pourquoi ce
sanctuaire mans n'est plus un certain
dit c'est peut-être un coup de la gauche
de quelqu'un qui voudrait que on se
mobilise qui est quelque chose il ya
déjà des premières mobilisations
d'autres se disent est plutôt
vraisemblement un coût des conservateurs
parce que qu'est-ce qui est en train de
se passer est sans doute le juge robert
c'est à dire le chief justice le le juge
en chef lui il est pas tellement
favorable il est hostile à la vente de
droits à l'avortement il est
conservateur mais il est protecteur de
l'institution et donc comme protecteur
de l'institution il faut pas qu'on il
veut peut-être qu'on grignote le droit à
l'avortement mais pas qu'on aille aussi
loin que de remettre en cause glaudon
qui se dit qu'ils étaient en train
d'essayer de convaincre le juge barrette
et jusqu'à vanot de changer d'avis mince
c'est publié s'est figé la presse en
parle la presse internationale en parle
donc se forge grave
reese d'être au final et puis une
dernière interprétation qui est de dire
en plus c'est une manoeuvre de diversion
seigneur par exemple là ça fait déjà
cinq minutes qu'on parle de ça du secret
de la course finale pour ne pas parler
du droit à l'avortement c'est peut-être
une fuite orchestrée par la droite
américaine et ça marche plutôt bien la
moitié des articles aux états unis sont
consacrés à ce secret éventé plutôt
qu'au droit à l'avortement alors dans ce
débat évidemment a passé beaucoup plus
de temps sur le droit à la vente à ce
qu'il sait faire et républicains m parce
que les démocrates sont sur le fond et
c'est vrai que cherry public est on est
on est beaucoup sur l'investigation qui
a fait ça voilà cc on est sur la forme
plutôt le font parce que ça fragilise
quand même un peu la cour suprême c'est
cette fuite ça c'est vrai que le rôle
d'un juge n'est pas de faire de la
politique et donc l'idée c'est que
malgré tout en l'espace de trente ans on
a vu se politiser à l'extrême
la cour suprême alors c'est vrai que la
nomination d'un juge à la cour suprême
ça a toujours été un élément politique
parce que précisément la cour suprême
dans un système où la justice a son
importance la cour suprême est garant de
la constitution mais on a bien vu aussi
au cours des trois quatre dernières
nominations que les sénateurs lors des
auditions insiste beaucoup sur les
opinions personnelles sur les opinions
religieuses sur l'environnement social
du juge alors qu on se serait attendu
concon s'appesantissent beaucoup plus
sur les décisions elles mêmes qui ont
été rendus l'économie sociale ou
politique d'une décision plutôt que la
conviction du juge d'ailleurs lors de la
dernière audition
le juge kenji brown je ne sais pas bien
préciser elle a dit mais on fond moi je
vais appliquer mon serment de magistrat
de vivre les choses de manière
indépendante de juger les faits par
rapport à la loi et de manière neutre
donc elle a rattrapé ce côté parce qu'il
ya une présomption contre elle parce que
nous mais part proposé par un président
démocrate il y avait une sorte de
présomption de laxisme par exemple en
matière criminelle mais alors vous
l'avez fait référence des dix lots c'est
cet arrêt il faut évidemment très vite
dans ce débat avec alexandre pour ça a
expliqué de quoi on parle cet arrêt de
la cour suprême de 1973 roe versus wade
décision qui a fait jurisprudence et qui
va peut-être être cassé alors il faut
nous raconter l'histoire de cette
décision oui car c'est un tournant dans
l'histoire des états unis alors tout
commence trois ans plus tôt en 1970 avec
cette femme norma mccorvey c'est une
mère célibataire de 21 ans enceinte pour
la troisième fois elles souhaitent
avorter mais l'état dans lequel elle vit
interdit l'avortement c'est le texas
alors elle décide de porter l affaire en
justice devant le tribunal de dallas et
pour le procès elle change même de nom
elle se fait appeler john howe et face à
l es bien pour défendre l'interdiction
de l'avortement il ya le procureur de
dallas henri wade c'est pour ça qu'on
parle d'arrêt au versus wade est dans un
premier temps et bien janeiro perd son
procès face à wade mais elle décide de
faire appel devant la plus haute
juridiction des états unis à la cour
suprême et trois ans plus tard et bien
tout bascule sept juges sur neuf de la
cour suprême adopte l'arrêt suivant 1 je
le cite le droit au respect de la vie
privée présent dans le 14e amendement de
la constitution est suffisamment vaste
pour s'appliquer à la décision d'une
femme de mettre fin ou non à sa
grossesse et donc les juges concluent
que l'état du texas violent viole la
constitution en interdisent l'avortement
est donc c'est une jurisprudence qui va
se décliner et qui va autoriser
l'avortement jusqu'au seuil de viabilité
du foetus c'est à dire entre 22 et 24
semaines le problème c'est que cette
décision de la cour suprême alexandre
elle a des limites dans sa rédaction si
oui un quart dans cet arrêt de 1973 et
bien il est stipulé que le respect de la
vie privée qui protège le droit à
l'avortement eh bien ce n'est pas un
droit absolu et que à un certain stade
et bien les intérêts de l'état et la
protection de la santé des critères
médicaux et la vie prénatale deviennent
dominant donc cela crée une ambiguïté et
cela permettra par la suite est bien à
certains états de mettre en place quand
même des restrictions à bien ce droit à
l'avortement est d'ailleurs la fragilité
de cet arrêt de 1973 et bien les
manifestants américains pro avortement
ils en sont conscients
cet arrêt de la cour suprême a toujours
était vouée à l'échec je suis en faveur
de l'avortement mais
constitutionnellement ce n'est vraiment
pas soutenu dans le texte ça a toujours
été une solution temporaire je blâme
davantage les démocrates qui pendant 50
ans ont eu l'occasion de garantir ce
droit par un amendement ou par une loi
ils n'ont pas fait
voilà c'est intéressant de voir que bien
sûr le camp des républicains fait
pression pour interdire le droit à
l'avortement mais que le camp des
démocrates n'a peut-être n'a peut-être
pas fait assez pour sécuriser ce droit
merci alexandre effectivement
marie-cécile d'avs les démocrates
auraient pu faire sécuriser ce ce droit
il n'y a pas de lois fédérales mais il
en existe une ici en france par exemple
il n'ya pas de lois fédérales et
d'ailleurs les débats qui sont
aujourd'hui en cours dans la société
américaine et qui est qu'ils sont portés
par un certain nombre d'élus démocrates
plutôt de l'ailé gauche du parti
démocrate les abattoirs n alexandre
occasion carte 16
dans les cent des recettes stade il faut
absolument maintenant voter une loi
fédérale ça paraît assez peu aussi voire
impossible parce que ça serait loin qui
nécessiterait les deux tiers d'une malle
de la majorité au sénat pour passer
l'obstruction des républicains et ça ne
ne fonctionnerait pas donc effectivement
c'est un droit qui est extrêmement
fragile et on rappelle aussi que la
constitution des états unis c'est la
seule constitution en démocratie qui
n'indiquent pas l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes donc il ya c'est
une constitution même dans lequel dans
laquelle le mot le mot femme
n'apparaît pas ou très peu jean-claude
faut peut-être expliquer à ce point du
de notre débat ce qu'est le l'importance
fin de la cour suprême dans le droit
américain c'est quand même assez
différent de ce qui se passe
nous nous ça n'est que depuis un peu de
temps que le conseil constitutionnel
joue un rôle aussi aussi élaboré qu il
le fait aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas ce
mécanisme alors qu'aux états unis c'est
vrai qu'au dessus il ya une vision une
vision très stricte aux états unis comme
si certains c'est la loi qui le pilier
sellita droit c'est la loi qui nous
piliers du système là où en france et
l'état donc on n'est pas sur la même
conception donc pour l'américain le fait
qu'il y ait un système judiciaire et un
juge qui tranche c'est le sait jusqu'au
bout sa garantie maximale donc c'est
vrai que la cour suprême demeure le
pilier drocourt les les vendre au cours
de n'importe quel de citoyens américains
et pour l'américaine fait qu'il puisse
recourir à la justice c'est le
sacro-saint c'est l'équivalent de notre
état donc c'est pour ça que une pause la
position de la cour suprême
et ce d'autant que la cour suprême va
beaucoup plus loin que simplement le
droit il faut bien qu'on comprenne qu'il
ya deux doctrines à comps suprême ceux
qui sont partisans et c'est ce qu'on
appelle les conservateurs d'une
application stricte du texte et donc
comme il a été écrit à plus de deux
siècles et ceux qui disent bien le texte
comme
ainsi attendre des progrès si ce qu'ils
disent le texte a vocation à être
interprété dans un contexte normal
immédiat et au quotidien donc c'est vrai
qu'on
voit s'affronter deux doctrines et
zagreb vraiment pour bien comprendre je
pose des question de béotien mais le
juge sur la base de la constitution
américaine
oui mais comme ça ex comme tout texte
lorsque vous avez des faits vous
interprétez défait par rapport au texte
alors il ya deux catégories de textes
des textes qui sont hyper seule la
majorité quand elle a 18 ans c'est pas
compliqué ça on n'a pas besoin d'y
passer six mois mais lorsqu'on vous dit
le droit à la vie privée ces croix le
droit à la vie privée c'est quoi la vie
privée il ya deux siècles c'est quoi la
vie privée aujourd'hui on le voit bien
même chez nous et on a des sujets qui
sont difficiles d'élaboration et n'a le
juge le juriste le travail du jury c'est
le réfléchir y compris en allant
beaucoup plus loin que le texte on
regarde un peu la philosophie voir en
regardant ce qui se fait ailleurs le
juge breyer par exemple qui est un
francophile un francophone
s'inspirait beaucoup de ce qui se
faisait en europe pour avoir des
concepts pour pouvoir d'ombré il ya
vraiment un travail de réflexion et ce
que dit le samu aito il dit mais
finalement le droit à l'avortement n'est
pas véritablement c'est pas dans notre
culture c'est pas dans la culture de
notre constitution séance et non mais ça
m'a dit oh c'est l'un des juges
c'est l'auteur de la colère de l'opinion
qui pourrait être l'opinion majoritaire
parce qu'il peut y lire l'union
dissidents que les choses soient claires
pour tout le monde beaucoup de réactions
aux états unis vous avez cités elizabeth
warren qui est sénatrice démocrate
ancienne candidate aux primaires
démocrates elle faisait partie des
manifestants devant la cour suprême on
écoute
je suis hors de moi parce que nous avons
une cour suprême des états-unis
extrémistes ou 5 personnes pensent
qu'elles peuvent dicter leur loi à des
dizaines de millions de femmes à travers
ce pays
[Musique]
ils pensent qu'ils peuvent décider pour
nos vies eh bien ils ont tort
[Applaudissements]
elizabeth warren qui qui combat
évidemment les pro-life les le lobby
entier un avortement marie-cécile nab ce
lobby pro life idées pour bien prendre
conscience et de sa puissance qu'est ce
qui représente aux etats unis
aujourd'hui mais peut-être depuis quand
il travaille la société américaine
depuis en gros les années reagan c'est à
dire c'est un tout un mouvement qui se
met en place justement pour prendre la
revanche sur les années de libération
des droits des femmes presque les la
revanche sur mai 68 en fait toute cette
révolution conservatrice qui se met en
place
quatre ans c'est un mouvement qui est
ultra-minoritaire aujourd'hui on la
société américaine il faut bien prendre
conscience de ça les deux tiers des
américains ça dépend des états et une
âme en sont les deux tiers des
américains sont favorables au droit à
l'avortement aujourd'hui since they qui
est beaucoup plus moderne qu'on pourrait
le penser de ce côté ci de l'atlantique
en revanche ce ses militants là ils sont
extrêmement influent extrêmement
puissant depuis les années 80 ils sont
financés aussi par des parts d
et des groupes économiques qui ont
intérêt à ce que ces idées là se propage
ils sont extrêmement puissant en termes
de lobbying politique auprès auprès des
élus on voit bien d'ailleurs que c'est
un enjeu avant tout locale avec une âme
un qui aujourd'hui est coupée en deux
très clairement qui est coupée en deux
entre des états des états qui sont très
défavorables importants et puis d'autres
dont on parle peu dans ce débat mais qui
qui le défendent et qui même ces
derniers jours ces dernières ces
derniers mois ont mis en place des
mesures pour sanctuariser le droit et
ouvrir des cliniques dé débloquer des
fonds pour erreur des cliniques pour
accueillir les femmes des états voisins
qui sont privés de ce droit mathieu est
ce que comme le disait dans le reportage
enfin comme je disais pardon alexandre
tout à l'heure les démocrates ont joué
avec le feu en sanctuarisant passe ce
droit à l'avortement par une loi et
s'ils ne l'ont pas fait pourquoi est-ce
que c'est par a peur de ces lobbys
est-ce que c'est abordable d'en faire un
sujet de société qui aurait été trop
clivant sous-estimer le danger et ce
sens c'est aussi une capacité de
mobilisation sur le terrain de
militantisme sur le terrain qui est très
très inégale donc d'un côté ou de
l'autre de l'échiquier politique
vraiment il ya un militant qu'on arrête
un militantisme ultraconservateur qu'on
a retrouvé aussi sous d'autres formes
moment du tea party souls en souvenez
dans les années 2010-2013 très influent
avec un une proximité vis-à-vis des
politiques une capacité à se faire
financer aussi qui est supérieur aux
associations de défense des droits des
femmes et puis il n'y a pas simplement
d'avortement qui est interdit ou gêner
dans certains états béraud va jusqu'à
dire qu'on pourrait engager des
procédures contre ceux qui apportent
leur concours la caricature la
caricature c'est le chauffeur de taxi
qui même on pourrait aller plus loin
même non intentionnellement c'est à dire
que même s'il n'est pas et qui
pourraient être poursuivis au point qu
hubert a dit ben moi j'assure et la
défense de ce qu ici ou là pour être
poursuivies dont vous voyez ça va très
loin il ya des états qui n'autorise pas
l'avortement et on criminalise le fait
les se faire avorter dans un autre dans
un autre état donc voyez ça il ya une
forme de il ya une forme de peur mais
c'est surtout la peur même si ça ne
fonctionne pas en réalité parce que
c'est trop compliqué mais il ya une
forme de peur mais alors c'est
intéressant parce que alors yahia savent
il ya aussi des états qui dès
aujourd'hui se positionne je pense à la
californie comme défenseur de ce droit à
l'avortement françois durpaire donc ce
qui peut se passer même on imagine que
la cour suprême soit sur la ligne de ce
premier draft comme vous ne l'avez dit
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que
toutes les femmes américaines ne
pourront plus avorté on est bien
d'accord pas du tout exactement en fait
c'est pas le passage à une
nationalisation de l'autorisation à
l'avortement à une
interdiction nationale interdiction pas
du tout et d'ailleurs si on dit 70% des
américains sont favorables à ne pas
revenir sur reversus wade il faudra
regarder un peu plus loin l'enquète si
on leur explique que revenir sur roberts
wade ce n'est pas interdire l'avortement
il n'ya plus que 50 50 52 pro-life 52
prochain en fait l'amérique et encore
moins divisée que cela parce que quand
on pose une question complexe les
américains répondent de manière complexe
compte leurs demandes avortement droit à
l'avortement au premier trimestre ils
sont 60% à dire oui quand on leur
demande droit à l'avortement au deuxième
trimestre ils sont 28% à dire oui donc
c'est pas eu les c ça va être des états
unis face à lavaur top au droit à
l'avortement en fait les américains sont
beaucoup plus complexe que cela ça c'est
pour l'opinion américaine
après ce qui va se passer c'est
qu'effectivement ou connaissez la fable
de la fontaine que l'on soit puissant ou
misérable à ce que l'on soit dans
l'idaho que son enfant en californie est
d'accord ça va pas être la même chose
nous y mettre une femme qui dans l'idaho
elle pourra pas faire des milliers de
kilomètres pour se déplacer
attaqué pour avoir changé d attrition
avorté jean claude a mis le point sur un
point très intéressant c'est les
conflits interétatiques qui vont se
produire petit 1 est ce que un état peu
comme c'est par exemple le cas du
missouri interdire qu'on est d'une femme
a changé l'état pendant qu'elle est
enceinte pour pouvoir accéder au droit
de l'avortement ailleurs 2 est ce que un
état peut donner sa production sa
protection sociale à une femme qui est
originaire or de l'état 3 est-ce qu'on
peut avorter via internet c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui a pas des frontières
d'état vous pouvez très bien avoir donc
risques en matière d'automédication
2 qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
maintenant on est dans une épître aux
quatrième et dernière complication quid
de la loi fédérale de la loi de l'état
fédéral par exemple à une loi fédérale
qui dit en cas d'urgence tous les
hôpitaux de du pays doivent ouvrir
notamment une femme par exemple quand un
problème médical et kid entendu qui
devrait subir une intervention est bien
là il ya loi fédérale qui est au dessus
de la loi d'état voyez un petit peu tous
les enjeux qui ont recours cela est là
le combat beaucoup de des progressistes
c'est de se dire il faut au moins avoir
accès là maintenant à une contraception
gratuite et qui passent pas par les
salariés de manoeuvre de bail donne
question alors là pour le coup très
politique on a on a les élections de
mi-mandat qui approchent allez allez
il a dit un truc très très sympa y donne
il a dit ce qu a dit jean-claude ça va
ouvrir la boîte de pandore à toutes les
lois sur la protection sur parce que ce
que dit habito dans le texte et 90 pages
il dit que
si c'est pas inscrit dans la tradition
américaine ce que vient de dire jean
claude ci s'est pas inscrit dans la
tradition américaine et s'il la
constitution ne le protège pas alors il
ya plein de choses pensée 2015 le
mariage homosexuel en 2015 ça ça va y
passer alors gestionnaire des
républicains d'un dernier mot c'est pas
que ce soit fédéraliser état par état le
rhin des républicains c'est de
sanctuariser ce que les démocrates n'ont
pas réussi à faire c'est à dire de
sanctuariser une nationalisation de
l'interdiction c'est ça leur sert
déclarations de joe biden on l'a
récupéré cet égard il ya il ya deux
jours effectivement il met en garde sur
d'autres combats à venir on écoute le
président américain
joe biden commentaires de la décision
tel qu'il a été publié et confirmer
toute une série d'autres droits serait
en question toute une série d'autres
droits et l'idée de laisser les états
prendre ses décisions les localités
prendre ses décisions serait un
changement fondamental par rapport à ce
que nous avons fait donc ça va bien au
delà à mon avis si cela se confirmait et
si ce qui est écrit et ceux qui restent
cela va bien au delà de la question de
savoir s'il existe ou non un droit de
choisir cela concerne d'autres droits
fondamentaux comme le droit de se marier
jean-claude beaujour donc là là où ils
anticipent d'autres arrêts de la cour
suprême non je crois que le présent
byden anticipé anticipe une question
c'est quand même un homme expérimenté il
anticipe un contexte politique et
maximum il ne nous aura pas échappé vous
avez projeter tout à l'heure la réaction
de madame roy règne qui quand même
sénatrice il n'est pas aussi fréquent de
voir un élu
avoir une position aussi forte vis-à-vis
d'une juridiction généralement on dit
qu'on est comment s'étonner c'est pas
c'est pas c'était dumerc en général on
ne s'attaque pas aussi violemment
regretter on emploie des mots je trouve
qu'on emploie des mots beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus fournie pour pouvoir dire
qu'on n'est pas d'accord on dit quoi là
et d'ailleurs le président biden avait
dit qu'il regrettait la haye la
viscéralement 1 a dit comment cinq
personnes c'est remettre en cause je
trouve que c'est une expression qui
tenta même remettre en cause la halle à
l'existence la légitimité de la
juridiction et 10 5 personnes peuvent
décider d'autres vite vous retenir
c'était une femme dernier passage non
madame je peux pas vous laisser dire ça
parce que je peux pas laisser ça parce
que précisément précisément jeudi que le
sujet va beaucoup plus loin je ne suis
pas je ne dis pas que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec ce qu'elle dit jeudi que
dans cette expression on sent qu'il va y
avoir un combat politique
voilà exactement et on peut imaginer que
joe biden en profite pour pouvoir
mobiliser son électorat le sli pidjot
dont on parlait et bien il va mobiliser
un maximum sur tous ces sujets parce que
marie cécile la bleue on va vous parlais
tout à l'heure du lobby pro life mais
les mouvements féministes
si on parle de l' influence de trump et
du mandat de donald trump se sont
peut-être ceux qui ont été les plus
présents les chimistes ont été très
présentes pour combattre le trajet
seller première force d'opposition à
trump dès janvier 2017 avec les women's
match et les féministes honteux vrai
énormément pour la victoire de baden en
2020 ça c'est vraiment en grande partie
grâce aux féministes pas seulement
est-il qu'il accède au pouvoir mais elle
mais ça reste quand même une institution
à la cour suprême qui est ultra
conservatrice est qui et qui sait
vraiment polarisé qui s'est politisé
avec avec le temps beaucoup plus qu'en
soit en qu'au début des années soixante
dix avec 7 c'est aussi les conservateurs
à l'époque qui vote l'accès à
l'avortement mais ce que dubai donne
quand il parle de d'autres combats à
venir et sait c'est que la loi sur le
mariage entre personnes de même sexe
elle est aussi fondée sur les 14e
amendement et la question du droit à la
vie privée donc c'est le même principe
qui fonde la rue revient suède et la
reine à 2015 felli fait il fait la
politique j'ai dit les élections mi
terme et donc les démocrates qu'est ce
qu'ils disent bas ils disent on n'en
voyait pas des démocrates au congrès
envoyer des pro choice au congrès c'est
ça qui va se passer si vous voulez
énonce pas seulement au congrès parce
que c'est pas le combat l accueil
vraiment je envoyer des gouverneur
démocrate ce que ça va être et à part et
a donc fait en sorte qu'ils aient oui ça
va les défendre ce
gouvernement l'état le procès fait en
sorte il est de skier y ait beaucoup
d'étapes pro-choice ça va être l'état et
est ce que c est ce que c'est un bon
pari d'abord il faut dire que la
question d'avortement est plus une
question on dit souvent ça fait partie
des guerres culturelles de l'amérique
pas tellement et dernières années c'est
pas tellement une guerre culturelle les
guerres culturelles par an si vous
prenez vous êtes au milieu de la table
vous lancez l'immigration trump et être
passé par là mais là c'est une
thématique vraiment extrêmement
prégnante quand vous prenez aujourd'hui
les enquêtes d'opinion le thème du droit
d'avoir peut-être parce que c'était
inscrit un peu dans les têtes personnes
s'imaginer que wade qui est quand même
extrêmement audacieux on passe de 22 ce
n vous imaginez en france par an pour
critique la loi du mississippi en disant
que c'est extrêmement conservateur c'est
une amérique puritaine ses quinze
semaines le mississippi la france et 12
semaines soit le nombre de semaines est
aussi le nom le nom de l'île et les
cliniques d'un superbe les conditions
dans la mitis en face de moi je suis
complètement favorable ci s'appelle
claire tu favorables ou versus ou et le
nombre de son nom tout à fait mais c'est
important de dire que quand la cour
suprême utilité conservatrice a dit en
1972 robert suède l'opinion publique
était pas très très avancé sur cette
question donc c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement audacieux et l'asca 10
mars il est tout à fait juste c'est à
dire que la effets de la politique la
cour suprême on s'imaginait un
grignotage du droit à l'avortement on
s'imaginait pas qu'il remette en cause
aussi rapidement quelque chose d'aussi
fondamental c'est pour ça se juge
roberts qui est qui et conservateurs lui
se dit mais qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce
qu'ils sont en train de nous faire ils
sont servis ce combat quand on commet
des deux donne à 30 les pro-life et ne
sont que l'argument il n'est que
religieux ou si on se dépasse les solos
j'ai dû regarder par exemple
les propos il ya quand même des propos
dans les 90 du page qui vous font un peu
vomir hilali taudis à un moment donné le
maximum de foetus qui ont été tuées ce
sont des foetus afro américains pourquoi
il dit ça alito parce qu'ils essaient
d'aller chercher la mito et aux afro
américaine qui sur le plan social est
extrêmement
évidemment à gauche mais sur le plan
sociétal qui sont beaucoup plus
conservateur ça veut dire que donald
trump il a réussi son coup finalement en
nommant ses juges conservateurs et
station même il a finalement il y ait
une espèce de rémanence il suffit cela
dans le débat dans le débat politique et
sociétale amérique
il émule que les lobbys camp ultra
léchée donald trump
présenté ce jour-là religieuse donald
trump n'est pas
passionné de la justice et et des jus du
monde juridique s'était passé copains
mais il s'est arrangé en tout état de
cause en servant de l'oubli une
conservateurs religieux se sont arrangés
madame est
annoncé très clairement sa position est
là sept ou huit enfants avec ces traces
sont des gens qui sont extrêmement
conservateur c'est en ce sens là qu'il y
a eu une forme de victoire non seulement
de donald trump mais aussi de tous ceux
qui se sentent j'ai envie dire de cette
dans cette nouvelle droite
sociale ccss révèle droite qui ferait
plus sens et surtout tu fais beaucoup de
pick est extrêmement
efficace dans le lobby qu'elle est
capable de faire ils sont à chercher
donald 30 pour salah fédéraliste society
ça fait des années qu'ils vont chercher
les juges ultraconservateur et la
feuille de route d'un train de céder
dire tu peux dire ce que tu veux
populiste ça très bien va chercher les
ouvriers dans le midwest etc en revanche
qu'un agenda conservateurs c'est d'aller
chercher dans la liste de la fédéraliste
society
les juges les plus conservateurs tu en
2003 hélas non pas 4 même site a qu'un
seul mandat tu va transformer la société
américaine pour des générations parce
que c'est pas un changement de droit
c'est un changement de gien je suis
saturé fluence la question que pose et
mathieu ce qu'évoquait mathieu sur la le
le poids finalement de la religion de
l'art religieux de la religion
chrétienne dans certains états est-ce
que l'on parle on peut parler de
théocratie est-ce que vous pensez que
certains états sont sur ce chemin je
vois là je mets des mets des guillemets
des bémols mais est ce que est ce qu'il
ya cette direction qui pourraient être
prises par ça oui mais beaucoup plus
chez les élus que dans la queue dans la
population en fait c'est comme ça d
obsession identitaire est de retour un
espèce d'âge d'or où la religion était
beaucoup plus présent dans la vie des
individus pendant l'année où le
président prête serment sur la religion
et à temps et entendre aux états unis
comme com
le moyen de créer de la commune faire de
la coupure communauté et faire du lien
c'est papa bas au sens où on l'entend
d'un autre
religion arrivera ensuite et nous est
déjà arrivé au congrès ensuite ce qu'il
faut voir c'est que les ultra
conservateurs avec donald trump qu'ils
ont une chance énorme c'était encore un
seul mandat il a la possibilité de
nommer trois juges c'est exceptionnel
c'est un non événement exceptionnel
mitch mcconnell et puis mitch mcconnell
a tué en veulent parce que il faut pour
ceux qui connaissent pas bien apprécié
des américains en tout cas moins bien
que vous c'est empêcher aubaine obama
doit pas de juger un juge voilà il ay là
il à empêcher obama de hull nommer un
juge au prétexte qu'il était dans son
alinéa élections dans sa dernière année
dont on aurait eu un juge progressiste
en plus et le même mitch mcconnell au
toit un an avant cinq semaines avant
l'élection de trump autorise trois
princes à nous mais bacor donc c'est
évidemment un scandale pour tous les
projets situés à malines et hiruma temps
c'est malhonnête et ils ont hélas ils
ont fait un ce qu'on appelle un show
vote un peu pour le fun ils ont ils
haïssent en train de voter les sénateurs
démocrates pour essayer de se compter
jobs en chine vous savez c'est le
démocrate qui va botter du côté des
républicains et puis vous avez deux
républicaines qui sont du côté du droit
à l'avortement mais c'est un vote pour
dire ben voilà on essaye de faire passer
ça dans la loi je reviens pardon je suis
peut-être un peu têtu mais sur la
question de la théocratie c'est
peut-être parce que j'ai trop regardé la
série la servante écarlate et que voilà
sa marque sa marque mais mes idées mais
quand même genre gens que bonjour est ce
que est ce que c'est c'est un risque
potentiel est ce que je vous croyais pas
ne pense pas je ne pense pas parce que
précisément il ya une distinction à
faire me semble-t-il entre les élus qui
sont j'ai envie de dire comme partout
parce que de plus en plus ces élus ont
tendance à regarder le sens du vent il
se dit je vais faire comme ça parce que
parfois ça fait un peu bien sinon donc
on est un peu excessif alors qu'il ya
des secteurs pour les mettre
sur ce programme parce qu'ils ont le
sentiment que ça peut plaire un certain
nombre de groupes alors que dans
l'amérique profonde et au quotidien vous
avez tout d'abord et pour répondre très
précisément à votre question parce que
vous disiez ce que certains états je
crois que c'est plus fluide que cela
alors même qu' à dix états du sud qui a
un côté avec les idées que l'on sait
mais par exemple on a des mouvements de
population qui se font aujourd'hui vous
voyez de la californie vers vers
l'arizona et c'est qui qui font que j'ai
du mal à imaginer que ce soit vraiment d
état complètement séparée compact avec
des traditions si forte voilà c'est
c'est mon sentiment ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut quand même avoir en tête
c'est que l'antiféminisme et les
opposants au droit des femmes dans les
structures patriarcales de la société ne
sont pas portés que par les religieux
mais c'est beaucoup plus partagée dans
la dans l'amérique ont à dire plutôt
conservatrice mais qui ne se reconnaît
pas nécessairement dans une religiosité
importante mais qui est imprégné de
valeurs patriarcales de traditionalistes
traditionalisme et qui est un peu la
nostalgie aussi d'une amérique des
années 50 où chacun est à sa place les
femmes d'un côté qui travaillaient pas
les zones etc et puis aussi il ya aussi
un peu cette nostalgie d'une d'une
amérique blanche il faut qu'on est très
claire la mairie albert de gace sur ce
droit comme et c'est pas uniquement le
droit à l'avortement il ya une menace
sur la contraception les mouvements
féministes se battent au quotidien et
d'ailleurs ont fait pression sur joe
biden qui est pas forcément le plus
progressiste en la matière catholique on
le rappelle pratiquant kim et qui enfin
dans sa carrière a quand même défendu
mais bon pour qu'ils remettent en cause
un certain nombre de dispositifs mis en
place par par trump et notamment pour
qu'on fasse revenir la fameuse fdea vous
savez lagence médicales américaines aux
niveaux au niveau fédéral notamment sur
le fait d'empêcher les femmes d'accéder
à une contraception libre et ça c'est
très important parce que si vous n'avez
en plus pas de droit à l'avortement et
qu'en plus vous n'avez pas d'accès à la
contraception
un certain nombre de notamment de jeunes
femmes plutôt issus des minorités ça va
être extrêmement complexe il ya une
réalité il ya le plus c'est ce public là
qui a le plus recours à l'avortement
sait il y avait un article du new york
times ses chances et qui en parle et un
public plutôt autour de la vingtaine qui
a déjà un enfant qui n'a pas les moyens
financiers d'en assumer un autre plutôt
dans les minorités chez les pauvres
parce que
elle a moins - accès à l'information
accès à la santé c'est un enjeu de santé
aussi l'avortement c'est un enjeu de
défense de la santé gynécologique des
femmes parce que parfois on avorte aussi
pour sauver sa vie c'est ce sujet remet
en lumière la fracture sociale profonde
aux états unis où il ya une amérique qui
qui gagnent très en 20 ans et puis il ya
une amérique où les minorités sont sons
sont très largement sont sur représentés
avec des difficultés de tous ordres et
le secteur je rejoins ce qui vient
d'être dit en matière de santé la santé
est un élément de grosses fractures
sociales aux états unis entre les
minorités me qui constitue aujourd'hui
une majorité et puis ceux qui ont occupé
qui ont les moyens plus généralement
parce que derrière l'avortement il ya
aussi celles qui pourront et il ya
toutes celles qui ne pourront pas merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle le titre de votre
livre
marie-cécile minable la démocratie
féministe réinventer le pouvoir en est
aux éditions calmann lévy et puis cette
bande dessinée françois durpaire elysées
avec un z
évidemment c'est le z2 zemmour c'est
chez moi de maurice édition